SPEAKING OF WHICH, THE DEATH OF
COMEDY AND DECENCY.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
AT THE START OF HER MONOLOGUE AS
A HEADLINER OF THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENTS ASSOCIATION
DINNER, MICHELLE WOLF, A
COMEDIAN, NEITHER MYSELF OR
ANYBODY ON MY STAFF AT EVER
HEARD OF, MADE PLAIN THE
DIRECTION SHE WAS HEADED IN.
>> GOOD EVENING.
HERE WE ARE, THE WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENTS DINNER.
LIKE A PORN STAR SAYS WHEN SHE'S
ABOUT TO HAVE WITH A TRUMP,
"LET'S GET THIS OVER WITH."
THAT'S WHAT YOU ARE GETTING
TONIGHT.
>> Laura: AT LEAST SHE HAD A
REALLY GOOD VOICE.
WELL, THEY GOT MUCH MORE OF IT.
THE PRESIDENT WASN'T IN
ATTENDANCE.
PRESS SECRETARY SARAH HUCKABEE
SANDERS, KELLYANNE CONWAY, AND
OTHERS FROM THE WHITE HOUSE WERE
AT THE DINNER.
THIS WAS SUPPOSED TO BE AN
EVENING TO CELEBRATE THE
FIRST AMENDMENT.
BUT OF ALL THE COMEDIANS THE
CORRESPONDENTS ASSOCIATION GOT
FIRED, THEY TURNED TO THE
OBSCURE MICHELLE WOLF.
>> TRUMP THINKS YARD SALES ARE
THROUGH THE ROOF.
AFTER TRUMP GOT ELECTED, WOMEN
STARTED KNITTING THOSE [BLEEP]
HATS.
WHEN I FIRST SAW THEM, I WAS
LIKE, [BLEEP].
I GUESS MINE JUST HAS LOT MORE
YARN ON EDGE.
YEAH.
IT SHOULD HAVE DONE MORE
RESEARCH BEFORE YOU GOT ME TO DO
THIS.
>> Laura: THAT'S AN
UNDERSTATEMENT.
THE CHOICE OF AN ASPIRATIONAL
COMEDIAN LIKE WOLF, WITH ONE HBO
SPECIAL, I GUESS, A FEW WRITING
GIGS TO HER CREDIT, TELLS US A
LOT ABOUT THE CORRESPONDENCE
ASSOCIATION.
TO SOME OF THOSE WHO COVER THE
WHITE HOUSE, LET'S FACE IT, WE
KNOW IT, ARE BRIMMING WITH HATRE
KNOW IT, ARE BRIMMING WITH HATRD
OF THIS PRESIDENT AND ALL THAT
HE REPRESENTS.
LET'S FACE IT, HE EMBARRASSED
THEM WITH HIS ELECTORAL VICTORY
AND HE CONTINUES TO PROVE THEM
WRONG DAY AFTER DAY.
AND HE ENDS UP REVEALING THEM
FOR WHO THEY REALLY ARE.
I HAVE TO SAY, GUYS, WHEN YOU
SEE THE FACES OF THE CROWD AT
THE CORRESPONDENCE DINNER, WHEN
THEY WERE CUTTING AWAY FROM THE
C-SPAN COVERAGE, IT WAS -- I WAS
THINKING, WAIT A SECOND, CAN WE
JUST HAVE A FULL SCREEN AND
READS AT THERE?
BECAUSE WE NEED TO SEE THE
EXACT -- WE NEED TO SEE THE
EXACT FACIAL EXPRESSIONS ON THE
REPORTERS WHO ARE LAUGHING AT
THE PARTICULAR TIMES WHICH WE
ARE ABOUT TO HIGHLIGHT.
WHEN YOU COMPARE WHAT SHE WAS
SAYING TO WHAT HAPPENED WHEN THE
PRESIDENT WAS SPEAKING IN
MICHIGAN, WOW.
>> BY THE WAY, IS THIS BETTER
THAN THAT PHONY WASHINGTON
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENTS
DINNER?
IS THIS MORE FUN?
I COULD BE UP THERE TONIGHT
SMILING LIKE I LOVE WHEN THEY
ARE HITTING YOU, SHOT AFTER
SHOT, THESE PEOPLE, THEY HATE
YOUR GUTS.
>> Laura: WELL, FOR THIS AND
OTHER STATEMENTS LIKE IT, THE
PRESS WILL FOREVER DESPISE
TRUMP.
UNLIKE OTHER REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENTS WHO RAN TO THE
NEAREST CORNER AND DID NOT
APOLOGIZE WITH THE MEDIA
ATTACKS, TRUMP RETURNED FIRE.
BY CHOOSING WOLF AS THEIR
AVATAR, THE D.C. MEDIA ELITE
HAVE CONFIRMED THEIR BIAS FOR
ANYONE WHO WILL GIVE THEM EVEN
THE SLIGHTEST BENEFIT OF THE
DOUBT.
BOY, WAS I GLAD MY KIDS AND I
WEREN'T WATCHING.
>> I KNOW PEOPLE REALLY WANT ME
TO GO AFTER TRUMP TONIGHT BUT I
THINK WE SHOULD GIVE THE
PRESIDENT CREDIT WHEN HE
DESERVES IT.
LIKE, HE PULLED OUT OF THE PARIS
AGREEMENT.
AND I THINK HE SHOULD GET CREDIT
FOR THAT BECAUSE HE SAID HE WAS